nobody gives a about your grid you
don't get it Gary I want people when
they come to my account to see it right
I'm like they're not coming to your
account cuz you're trying to make it
look right you need the first part to
work meaning I get it like I don't want
to discredit people going to a grid and
getting like I I I love brand but
man 90% of the actions in feed so if
you're doing grid for the aesthetic but
it's not following best practice to
reach the most audience in feed to what
you're trying to do what the are
you accomplishing you know this a lot of
you are getting up because you
care about aesthetic you want your grid
to look right nobody gives a about
your grid you want to really get
at it doesn't matter it's the content
it's the
content